it is time for this week's pet project
lori herron joins us from the nspca and
she brought along someone
who needs a safe and good home little
kitty cat today
lori how you doing i'm good hi kendall
this beautiful siamese is cleo
she is a four-year-old girl she has been
with us for about a month which is too
long
and she has beautiful blue eyes i don't
know if you can
yes yes absolutely in the video and she
is as you can tell a wonderful lab cat
we do um recommend that she's the only
cat
in a house because she doesn't seem to
get along with other cats which
might just be cat behavior kendall but
yes we do try to
offer guidance so that it's the best fit
for any home when we adopt the animals
here at nevada spca
uh she'd be a wonderful addition for
somebody that
doesn't currently have any other cats in
the home right cats are not known to be
the most social animals in the first
place right
no you know what's interesting is we
keep our cat our cats at nevada spca
in colony rooms and there are many
instances where we have cat fights
because sometimes that's just the nature
of
how cats behave and some of them like
cleo need to be a little bit more of a
diva
like others and as you can see she has
the looks to be a diva
yes um with that gorgeous coloring and
those beautiful
blue eyes and again she's only four
years old
she's healthy she has a little bit of a
skin allergy so we recommend that she's
on a prescription diet
but she would be a wonderful addition to
a home
and again she's a young girl so she
would um be able to live with your
family for a long time
yeah she looks like a sweetheart too
people can come down and meet her make
sure they gel right
absolutely you know at nevada spca we
continue to do adoptions by appointment
just go to nevadaspca.org
and book your appointment and this
friday all of our adoption fees are
waived thanks to our partner lasik of
nevada
for our adopt till you drop black friday
sale so
you can make an appointment now for a
cat like cleo
and the adoption fees that we paid for
this friday black friday
by lasik of nevada lori thank you so
much happy thanksgiving to you thanks so
much for joining us today
thank you there's the information on
your screen give them a call if you're
interested in clio or any pet for that
matter rocky
thank you